[Music]
you might not have known that Martin
Luther King's doctorate was in theology
the left have been diligently scrubbing
much of the religious references from
King's legacy ignoring his deep
Christian faith as the source of his
activism on behalf of equality joining
us now for reaction my old friend radio
producer Lee habib currently a columnist
for townhall who joins us from Memphis
Tennessee and in Columbia South Carolina
Antoine see Roy Democratic strategist
and CEO of blueprint strategy gentlemen
great to see both of you Lee you just
wrote about this today you believe that
much of the King legacy has become
secularized how so well listen to the
media talk about King it's going to be
dr. King dr. King dr. King and not
Reverend King listen to the speeches
they play
it's the secular ones I would urge your
audience to go to google and type in
knock at midnight sermon and it's a
knock at midnight sermon a deeply
religious sermon or when Jesus calls a
man a fool indeed the source of Martin
Luther King's inspiration was a book
called the Bible which he quoted more
than any hundred books combined Laura we
have actually a a graphic of the speech
you're talking about the sermon you're
talking about Martin Luther King moral
principles have lost their
distinctiveness for modern man absolute
right and wrong are a matter of what the
majority is doing right and wrong are
relative to likes and dislikes and the
customs of a particular community
we've unconsciously applied Einstein's
theory of relativity which properly
described the physical universe to the
moral and ethical realm this mentality
has brought a tragic breakdown of moral
standards and the midnight of moral
degeneration deepens Antoine I love that
passage that Lee put in his column today
but he's right you don't really hear dr.
King talking about moral relativism I
don't know what he would think about
what's happened to our country today but
that was pretty amazing
well unless I'm living in some other
universe that you guys are not living in
the reference to dr. King's that we make
here in South Carolina and place I go is
Reverend dr. Martin Luther King because
he was a pastor before he was all those
other things and if you look at dr.
King's body at work and the things he's
thought he's fought for justice and
equality and fighting for the least of
these he really stood for what the Bible
talks about in Matthew 25 and 40 and
doing and fighting for the Lisa T's well
when you look at what's going on in our
country right now Laura I don't think
that dr. King will be pleased about the
current people occupying our government
on what they feel and what they're doing
towards the Lisa T's now the King was
about expanding our rights to vote at
the ballot box he was about health care
for everyone he was about making sure
that we have a fair and balanced
criminal justice system he was about
making sure that poor people have the
resources they need to because out of
certain situations I don't think we had
that going on right now in that
government Laura okay so let's see what
CNN tweeted today you say people are
recognizing Kings religious legacy the
people I know I was in the church today
where we were as dr. King jr. well in a
church that makes sense but I'm talking
on you know regular media CNN's tweet
he's an environmental hero he was a
socialist before it was cool he never
let a political disagreement turn nasty
many Americans have turned up Martin
Luther King into a safe holiday mascot
but some say King still speaks in ways
that go beyond civil rights he was a
socialist before it was cool leave what
about that you know it will be
interesting now to look at what dr. King
when Martin Luther King and Reverend
King would think about the lurch to the
left in America and Europe because
everywhere in the world the government
wins further left the churches gets
smaller the churches get smaller and
Antoine this is just a fact and we know
in this great country that the out of
wedlock birth rate is 40 percent that's
white black and Latino combined and I
would love to know what Reverend King
would think about this dissolution of
marriage in this country you know you
know
you know how big hurry so now I'll be
curious to know what Reverend King would
think about the leader of the few work
of the free world saying call the NFL
athletes who are peacefully protesting
sob I would love to see what Reverend
King were talking about a budget that
comes out of the White House that cuts
programs like me you're making the point
of the segment what you said wasn't
valid the point of the segment is Martin
Luther King based his philosophy on the
Bible and when he talked about moral
degeneration that went right to the
heart of what Lee was just saying the
degeneration of their daily once that
once the family dissolves as it has
across all racial lines especially hard
hit our african-american families and
young men it's hard hit once that
happens government can really not save
you it can't save you that's the half
that's a government we have to
government government can be a bootstrap
for a number of people to pull them out
of certain situations it's called
investing where we need to be trying to
50 years file or we have not then that
effectively we have not look at look at
k-12 education in this country
okay are you first choice are you for
certainly I am totally against school
choice because it will I would invest
equally Laura I want to be equally in
school what I would like you know you
you certainly can't blame Trump for
Chicago you certainly can't blame Trump
for Baltimore we don't know what Martin
Luther King would probably think our
policies in this country that really
hurt a certain segment of population
don't talk when I'm talking and I'll let
you talk but we're out of time but
Barack Obama was president for eight
years
we had skyrocketing crime and among
hard-hit communities that Martin Luther
King did care a lot about in Baltimore
and
rump SWAT it's it wasn't on Donald
Trump's watch it was on the Democrats
running those cities who are more
interested in keeping people angry than
giving people real solutions that's my
view guys great segment